- What was the moment you knew
you had to dedicate your life
to working with chimpanzees?
- Well, first of all, it was Africa.
I read Tarzan of the Apes
and fell in love with him.
And I was very jealous,
he married the wrong Jane.
(audience and guests laughing)
- He really did.
- So that was when my
dream of Africa began.
I grow up, go to Africa,
live with wild animals
and write books about them.
And everybody laughed, except, again, mom,
she said if you really want
to do something like this,
you'll have to work really hard.
Take advantage of every opportunity.
And if you don't get up,
hopefully you find a way.
Which I've spread that around the world,
especially in disadvantaged communities.
And so many people have
said, Jane, thank you.
You taught me because
you followed your dream,
I can follow mine.
So anyway,
I got out there.
- Absolutely. It's inspiring.
- Yes, I met Dr. Leakey.
I would've studied any
animal to be in nature
and he offered me the one most like us.
I mean, it's like fate, isn't it?
It was meant to be.
And so chimpanzees, I was sent off to be
the first person ever
to study chimpanzees.
- That's incredible.
So did you have anything
you wanted to ask Dr. Jane?
- No, I'm just,
I hope I can be a mom like your mom was.
It's really inspiring
because all of the things
that you said, it's true.
Like our instincts are to go,
oh, don't do that, it's messy.
But in reality, all of
those little things,
they really do form a person.